the Sun is around 4.5 billion years old
and just like you and I it's aging in
just over a billion years the Sun will
have expanded so much that the heat will
begin to melt the Earth's surface so is
there any way as Earthlings can avoid
this detrimental event can we save
ourselves from the sun's ultimate death
sure none of us will be here assuming we
don't find the secret to everlasting
life but at the billion year mark the
Sun will have used up the hydrogen fuel
in its core forcing it to burn at its
surface the increased radiation will
boil away all of the water on earth
creating an international desert
flash-forward about 5 billion years and
the swelling Sun will begin literally
melting mountains with most if not all
life on Earth now extinct around 7.5
billion years the expanding Sun now a
red giant will engulf the earth entirely
sounds bleak so can we avoid this hot
mess it turns out our best bet lies in
something called gravity assist a
technique we've been using for years
only to launch spacecrafts throughout
our solar system any time a spacecraft
or satellite comes in close proximity to
a planet gravity grabs hold and if the
spacecraft arrives at the perfect angle
its able to use some of the planet's
velocity to catapult it further into
space this extra energy comes from the
planets own energy of motion around the
Sun but as Newton famously said to every
action there is an equal and opposite
reaction as the spacecraft uses the
Earth's gravity to speed up and move
towards Earth the planet will ever so
slightly slow down and move towards the
spacecraft of course the spacecraft's
mass is so small comparatively that it
gets launched incredibly far while the
planet experiences little change but if
we were to increase the spacecraft size
or use an asteroid we could potentially
move the Earth's orbit away from the Sun
this would take millions of years and
involve large objects coming just close
enough to not collide with earth but hey
we've got a billion year head start
it may seem far-fetched but it's already
happening on October 9th 2013 earth will
be used to gravity assist a spacecraft
called Juno which is on its way to
Jupiter as Juno flies within 559
kilometers of us it will use Earth's
gravity as a slingshot to boost its
velocity by seven point three kilometers
per second meanwhile earth will have
been moved by a
action Juna will later arrive at Jupiter
in 2016 where it will study the interior
of the planet and help to unveil many
new spectacular mysteries of our solar
system in order to move the earth within
our billion year timeline we would need
approximately one encounter every six
thousand years using an object with the
mass of approximately 10 to the 19
kilograms that's 19 zeros somewhere
around the size of a 100 kilometer wide
asteroid in between passes the asteroid
would slingshot around the Sun fly up to
Jupiter and then be gravity assisted
back to earth like one long version of
catch between planets over millions of
years this would move the earth to a
comfortable 225 million kilometre orbit
out from the Sun and while it is
feasible even with today's technology it
doesn't come without risks for one we
may lose the moon which could ultimately
create some extreme weather patterns not
to mention the Earth's spin may increase
making days only hours long the
surrounding planets like our new
neighbor Mars would likely have their
own orbits destabilized and you know the
asteroid could come plummeting into
Earth by accident but perhaps these are
the risks we need to take to give our
descendants the planet and all life on
it a few extra billion years got a
burning question you want answered ask
it in the comments or on Facebook and
Twitter and if you want to learn more
about Juno check out it's awesome
interactive website we've linked in the
description special thanks to NASA for
inspiring and supporting this episode
and subscribe for more weekly science
videos
[Music]